[Music]
what the hell that thing has other
settings oh wow
is it bluetooth connected he's connected
to us can i buy ads for that yeah
yeah yeah
is there anything else we could pay you
to put on there oh my god look at this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that's flapping can you put anything on
it oh that's not yeah i can do whatever
can you put the kendra i did the woo
look i could do hinges if i wanted to
kill myself
well i mean speaking of
cool and trendy street wear
oh my gosh and everybody knows i hate
kinses so we're gonna leave it in
everybody knows that okay
no no that's my that's something
that's right that's my least favorite
dance crap i [ __ ] hate the kendra's
no you don't know who ginger's is good
keep it that way you're fine keep it
that way it's a dance group yeah
they try to be okay
yeah exactly i have a real blind spot
just like with the royal family but with
the dance company think about dan think
of it like oh a bunch of dancers with a
bunch of posers
well you must have heard of jabbawockeez
yeah that's the only one i know they're
huge and that's the only one that you
should know is it yeah like that's all i
need to do
that's all i got
hey
look at that are you in the excuse me
you look so familiar yeah yeah people
ask us as collectively as a group we're
all walking into a hotel somebody asked
we're like are you guys the jab walking
and afterwards she followed up with is
that a racist question yeah yeah and
we're like no but yes yeah and i was
like not at all yeah because we're we
are kind of are you guys a very
successful dance girl i don't know it's
a little racist
[Laughter]
it's a little racist thanks for that um
anthony you're welcome
so uh streetwear
in the stream where you're familiar with
streetwear
obviously obviously look at his hat a
little bit familiar
tight beast type beast it's a tiny
little bit yeah i know so there's a
bunch of really interesting reactions
right now because kith unveiled their uh
fall 2022 collection with jerry seinfeld
yep the star of the shoot is jerry
seinfeld wow wow you guys think he looks
pretty cool huh yeah very cool wait he
actually is down for this that's what i
was i was really surprised because and
the pictures came out pretty sick yeah
it looks dope but he's like notorious
for like not wanting to do a whole lot
yeah yes that's true
yeah i've only heard really bad stories
about him as an individual like i've
heard like terrible stories yeah from
people that i really trust no way like
what have you heard well i've heard he's
a dick he's a jerk for that too but also
of course he is yeah right yeah
that's to brand think of him as like a
charitable generous human being did you
watch the documentary of him no the one
where he did in the gosh it was like in
the 90s but it was like about you know
the the rise of this one stand-up guy
and like jerry seinfeld's in the
documentary and he's being told dick to
the guy oh yeah that's right yeah i
remember this
um
was it his dock or was it someone else's
it was his dock it might have been his
docker thing yeah but it was but it had
this other guy in it it was called
something like the comedian yeah i think
so yeah and it was about someone trying
to make it in this stand-up scene and
this he's just like a bully the entire
time
him bullying people
also yeah and also for whatever reason
he somehow he continues to evade this
but he dated a 17 year old for a very
long time oh really he was like 38 yeah
yeah he was set at 38 she was 17 and
then
[Music]
he wasn't this was like at the peak of
his career
and everyone's like he's she's 17. but
at that time you know it was the 90s i
think he was in international waters
which is totally fun he was on a boat
most of the time yeah epstein island
yeah
i love the campaign i'm actually most
impressed that the photographers
describe mark saljer he's
uh iconic 90s photographer he shot a lot
of famous jerry photos
and the fact that they got mark for this
i think is like that one that's what
impressed me the most because ronnie
does a lot of really cool campaigns like
this and the clothes are fine they look
actually very similar to amileondor
which is like running adjacent to kith
right now
but the clothes are fine like everything
about school but the photographer i
thought was like the most important part
they're my neighbor
at the royal hawaiian the kids kids
store oh yeah yeah i like their ice
cream
they're your neighbor
we're like kind of cool you know i'm i
have been surprised by how
far this has gone the it's ended up
everywhere and people it made a lot of
people excited what exactly is it though
it's um why did it why is it no what
exactly is it kith is a clothing kit is
a struggle
i'm sorry i don't know wait but did it
start because of mike tyson saying kiss
is that what it is no okay
it's a play off of uh it's
you know it's like fantastic because i
saw like holding the dubs yeah and
making them now kiss
and i saw mike tyson on a t-shirt and it
says kip that's really good that's why i
thought that's where it came from like
it was a troll brand
that's right but it's not
this is how much i know about streetwear
you know what i mean free alternate
publicity
alternate they should come out with a
mike tyson collab and everything is
kiffing we're fans we're gonna kiss
so what are the origins of kith
uh ron that sounds like you're saying
yes
ronnie has been involved in the business
for a really long time his family's also
been like deeply in stretch with like
the david c stores and he was doing
different mock-ups of asics and like
saucony collabs for the shoe store and
got a lot of notoriety for that and then
started his own thing and it's massive
he's one of the hardest working people
in the business wow he's notorious for
just like how serious and intense he is
about the work and they just do a really
good job you know i think it's more
prevalent just i think the impact is
deeper on the east coast it's more of
like an east coast brand but they are i
mean this is proving that they have like
a lot of global worth now because it
ended up that campaign ended up
everywhere and uh it's it's cool to see
but i'm also like what was it about this
campaign in particular because a lot of
streetwear brands do this someone was
just like oh they they should have
gotten larry david like larry david i
like larry this i think for mad happy
recently um and so there's and kef does
these kind i think they had um who else
have they had you know you'll see a lot
of like these famous actors do these
campaigns but and they make news in this
world
but for whatever reason this one is the
one that transcended one above ground
but putting putting larry david in it's
a little different because that's like
putting a wrinkly old towel in like a
cape and
i love larry davey i love larry david
he's still cool dude yeah he still
dresses cool when you dress like that
when you're a certain age it looks
[ __ ] nuts bro
it looks nuts that's why it's cool i
feel like david letterman could pull it
off oh yeah now he can yeah he's got his
cool look he's very you'd always like
unbutton the the one button whenever
he'd stand up that was like his stick on
the shoulder nothing i'm so old is the
theme 90s is that why is there is no not
at all option 90 oh okay no i think they
just like playing with a lot of
historic new york figures or new york
brand i think jerry's like a very new
york character yeah see i would have put
leonardo on there from the ninja turtles
as a baby
that's true
yeah the rest of the guys are california
yeah they're californian by actually
yeah
no how did that happen i have no idea i
recently also saw jerry seinfeld on the
cover of a
superman comic book he was actually on
the cover with superman was he dating a
17 year old in the comments you know
well it was a drawn picture so she's not
actually 17. you're right
i overstepped that's kind of she's
ageless no um he was sitting in the
batmobile with superman and then batman
was in the back and it was like
comedians and cars but like he was with
superman yeah and that makes it canon to
the batman universe i don't [ __ ] know
i think it was just a cover but oh yeah
because it's off his show i thought it
was kind of like archie meets punisher
kind of thing
no but yeah his show was real in
seinfeld he had superman like apparently
in every um in his apartment there was a
superman something
oh that's pretty cool just so amazed
like i wish i i could find out what they
told him in the pitch to get him to do
it i'm assuming i don't know this for
sure just i think he's a fan so mark the
photographer mark soldier he wrote this
whole copy about how mark was a fan like
he said a few years ago i walked into
the store and i was really obsessed with
it and then they asked me to shoot this
campaign he said i was happy to do it
because i don't just to pay these guys
we were talking about this the other day
like what would you have to pay i think
you would have to pay millions to have
for a photo shoot for a photo shoot i
would believe i mean just to get
most celebrities in issues like hundreds
of them what was the most expensive
you've paid for a photo shoot i don't i
try not to oh really people just give
you free stuff no it's just more because
we don't like doing a lot of celebrity
stuff it's more just i'll still work
with you though every person brand so
yeah it's yeah and i'll give you a free
yeah
this brings a full circle of like all
model for you for free
yeah i got you free free free
do you think that um to get seinfeld
it's kind of like shark tank where
they're like i'll take the royalty deal
and i'll give you 10 you give me 10
cents i'm sure yeah
i'm sure his lawyer and manager did
something like that you know like gotta
be something like that [ __ ] because
yeah that thing went far that's ty crazy
would would you ever want to be on shark
tank as a as a judge
as a shark i think so i don't know why
don't you pitch to them pretty cool yeah
that would be so funny if you pitch one
of your successful businesses that they
they don't even know about and then see
if they'll take it they're like that's
gonna fail
and then at the end you're like [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] successful with this [ __ ]
you know the deal with that show i think
they eventually had to curb it was
people were just using it for marketing
yeah like they never had the intention
it was great they might never as seen on
shark tank because you can get like a
better deal after the show exactly well
you know you're gonna lose all your
product being on shark tank like if you
have a warehouse full of stuff that's
gone after shark tank yeah apparently
even if it sucks especially if it sucks
right like any as seen on tv thing it
just [ __ ] goes there's a whole store
of as seen on tv yeah they should do
lasting on shark tank that's the story
they need
they
[Laughter]
yeah i honestly think that's probably
one of the greatest shows ever made i
love it it's great so great have you
seen the so there's a japanese version
that they licensed called the dragon's
den and they're [ __ ] oh that's the
japanese that's
too long i always thought it was just
another one have you tried to watch it
it's too long bro but the [ __ ] that they
say is crazier says you better [ __ ]
get your money back like aren't there
people from and they're begging for it
they're like begging for the money
they're like please they also have a
yeah they have a uk dragonstone too it
was also boring and [ __ ] plus i couldn't
understand anything they're [ __ ]
saying because they're all british
people
i like how the japanese one was fine but
then the british one you're like what
language
i don't know here what's the exchange
[Music]
[Music]
now